days after actor Nathan chasing horse
was arrested and accused of sexually
assaulting underage girls and what
police are calling a cult called the
circle a former member of that cult is
talking to eight news now Sasha Loftus
spoke with her as she detailed her
experience Sasha joined us with a story
you'll only see right here on 8 News Now
where chasing horse was arrested now she
tells me a member who later became her
boyfriend took her in when she was 17
and homeless and things just escalated
from there
I was told to you know basically treat
him like a king Courtney Ward describes
what life was like living with Nathan
chasing horse from day one I I was
abused uh verbally mentally and
physically she says she belonged to his
cult known as the circle for about a
year and even had a baby with another
member the ward escaped months ago she
touches on what she remembers including
what were called ceremonies all the
windows would be blocked out you know
and um you wouldn't be able to see
anything she says in that Darkness music
would play as contact was made with
Spirits I started seeing flashing lights
you know
um and I heard roddling I even felt
something touched me one time she also
claims many were given concentrated
forms of marijuana called medicine or
Phoenix Tears and in ceremonies who had
come with the girls in a straight line
Ward tells me those girls were chasing
horses wives many of whom investigators
believe were forced to have sex with him
as minors she also says she witnessed a
member's daughter chosen before she was
12 years old we were told that she was
like uh different you know like she was
special
and we I never understood what that
meant Courtney adds when chasing horses
helpers tried to trap and threaten her
she got away and now that she's safe she
hopes her story can help others
understand just have to trust your guts
sometimes because I didn't trust my gut
and I should have the whole time
Sasha hearing from her just a lot of
heavy information there from that
interview you conducted did she mention
to you how much she actually interacted
with Nathan chasing horse Brian she says
because she was not Native American she
was not allowed to speak with him
directly but she said he was always
quiet and everyone was really expected
to treat him in her words as quote more
than human now Courtney says her
daughter who she had while she was part
of the circle is still with family
affiliated with chasing horse very
complex story a lot of layers continue
to stay on it and we'll stay on it on
8newsnow.com